all right you seven so here's what I
would like you to do could you please
take those cards nice save uh take those
cards pop them back inside the box for
me all of them as you're doing that just
quickly look on the floor around you
because I have used playing cards in
teaching Maths for many many years I'll
tell that for you and um one of the
things that's always challenging is
every time you use them when I take them
back to the staff room I'm also always
missing one or two so um sometimes this
is not an example but sometimes a trick
requires every deck uh sorry every card
in the deck and so we don't want to lose
any right so just double check you
haven't accidentally dropped one uh
especially if you've got a green deck
cuz it Blends in okay now once you've
done that I'd like you to open your
books with me okay because some of you
have been writing down a few things and
taking notes others of you have not
that's totally fine but you will need
your book for this pit because I would
like all of you
you're giving me eye contact which is
good but you're not getting out your
book which is not so good so please get
out your then go get it get your book
out and if you want to make a heading
you can call
this Jack the hunter if you want thank
you Jack the hunter the day today is the
17th of
October and what I'm going to do is um
actually you can thank you thank you
I'll take that but you can leave your
cards I I'll come and collect them in a
moment but um if you still got yours on
your desk just leave it that's totally
okay smooth well done all
right
so what I'm going to ask you to do is
I'm going to ask you to write with
me an explanation of what I'm doing up
here but particularly not just like he
put down a card but I want you to
explain to yourself oh oh that's the
that's the concept or that's the the
mathematical bit that explains what is
going on so that's not all of it it's
not a trans script you're going to have
to be thinking hard with me about which
bits are important which bits aren't
don't worry I'll give you a hand I'll
pause at bits that I think are super
important if I don't see you writing
I'll be like hey this this is an
important bit right just to to send it
home to you okay so what you can see in
front of me is uh something a little bit
unusual this is something I tell people
to never do which is to mix together the
different decks of cards because it's
just a recipe for like ending up with
mixed up decks but you're going to see
why it's actually very useful for us to
have a few colors here to understand
what is happening in mathematics when
you're solving a problem you often get
presented with lots of information lots
of different numbers and symbols and
part of what is important or I should
say part of the skill of being a good
mathematician is being able to see when
are the details important and when are
they
unimportant remember at the beginning of
this uh trick I asked you to shuffle the
de and make it all mixed up right was it
important to the performance of the
trick that you shuffled your
deck no it wasn't right it wasn't
important because as you went through
right apart from the Jack you weren't
really looking at all at any of these
cards and what they were you treated
them exactly the same way whether it was
a four or a six or a 9 it didn't matter
right so this is the kind of thing where
when you're in a mathematics problem
right you might see for examp ex
literally just yesterday the year 12
they did their HSC mathematics exams
most of them anyway there's one more
left on Friday but most people did their
math exams on Friday some of the
questions are like a page long like an
A4 page right now part of what it means
to be a good mathematician is looking
through that and saying ah some things
are important some things are not one of
the things that is important which
wasn't obvious when I first did the
trick and that's why I'm highlighting it
to you now is that when you have a think
about I'm just going to recreate the
trick as we did it before right being
able to see where your piles go as you
divide them as you combine them is very
very useful right so do you remember I
had my Jack the hunter right I'll just
put it here so you can see it and then
you had your mystery card okay now I've
just by chance picked a nine of diamonds
but it doesn't really matter what it is
right it could be anything and I've just
picked a yellow card just so you can see
it more easily okay so that's there then
you've got do you remember can you help
me remember what what are these two
piles piles of 15 cards so I'm going to
call this one your 15 it's red and this
one's my 15 it's blue okay now what did
we do at the beginning we separated
these into two different piles like so
okay now remember how I gave you choice
and in fact I didn't look carefully as
to how I divided them right what that
should signal to you is it actually
doesn't matter how it's divided I could
even have put for example I'll do it
just for the sake of illustration I
could have put just a single let's make
it neat a single blue card over here
it's just one there you go and not had
any more right so it doesn't even have
to be even close to half right and then
I was going to hide your card and then
hijack the hunter how did we do that do
you remember what we did yeah go ahead
um you plac Jack the Hun on one side one
pile and you place um the yellow card on
one one p of mhm so then I actually did
Jack later but it actually doesn't
matter whether I do it sooner or later
um I would then bury it your secret card
between one of these two blue ones which
one would you like by the way left or
right people always love left um there
it goes hidden inside there and then
Jack the hunter gets hidden in the other
one okay now just look at what we've got
at the
moment here is your card hiding in here
and then here is Jack the hunter hiding
in here now at this stage what do we do
with these two piles we you st them I I
stacked them one on top of each other I
combined them right now just watch this
really carefully this is what the colors
are for okay suppose I put jack pile on
top can you see once I put jack pile on
top what do you notice about the blue
cards they're all
together right what if I didn't do that
what if I didn't put Jack's pile on top
what if I put it on the bottom here it
goes ah now all the reds are together
now here's one of the wonderful things
right the blue pile and the red pile you
know exactly how many cards there are
right there are 15 15 so now we know now
we know there are exactly whichever way
I did this right let me let me pull this
out wherever way whichever way I did
this there would always be exactly 15
cards
between Jack the Hunter and your Target
card so far so good here's my first spot
where I'm subtly saying hey if you
didn't write that down it might be a
useful piece of information that these
two
cards the Jack the Hunter and the Target
Card are 15 cards apart now let me um
let me leave this on the table and I'm
just going to come to the Whiteboard for
a
minute I need another color where's my
red one we go I've got red got a blue in
here okay so let me draw with you this
situation okay I think I've got enough
right so at the moment I've got
some red
cards then I've
got Jack the hunter then I have all of
the blue cards right they're all there
in the middle you can see them so I'm
just going to draw a big you get the
idea okay uh then here's your I don't
have a yellow marker sorry about that
let's call this your target or your
mystery card and then what do I have
underneath
that the rest of the red cards right so
that's what you can see kind of got a
card sandwich going on here okay now now
I don't know and you don't know how many
red cards are on top but it could be
anything couldn't it could be anything
so let's just come up with an example
right just have a look at it right now
what does it look like roughly to
you looks like five I think five is
about right so let's all say that there
are five cards here so counting from the
top what position is Jack the hunter in
right now six number six cuz there are 1
2 3 4 5 and then Jack comes in at number
six number six okay now you already know
there goes red there are 15 cards in
between think carefully before you shout
out an answer you know how there's five
cards on top and then Jacks at number
six when I go all the way down where is
the Target Card
sitting
H now I could actually start counting it
out right right but notice how there's
five cards and then this is the sixth
one so if there are 15 cards if you
added on 15 you'd get 21 is this card
number 21 no it's not in exactly the
same way as this is not card number five
right what card is
it it's card number six which makes this
one card
number
22 in case you missed that how did I do
that right to get from you know the
beginning to Jack the hunter I had to
add six even though there are five cards
cuz it's in the sixth position same
thing here when I go all the way down I
don't add 15 because there's one left on
the bottom so I add what 16 okay
position number six position number 22
okay why is this important can you
remind me what happens next like at this
point I've got all the cards in one pile
what do I do next someone you guys have
been so helpful to me thank you someone
else who hasn't given me a suggestion
yet you all remember you did this trick
right what do you remember Shuffle it
into two okay so I'm going to divide it
into two different piles now very
importantly you use the word Shuffle I'm
actually not shuffling and that's very
important to me right shuffling is that
technical word that we use for mixing up
the cards I actually am not mixing them
up I'm very carefully dividing them and
that's important now because I've made
our card yellow you'll see it very
obviously oh there it is it's with Jack
the hunter can you see Jack the hunter
hiding under there there go the rest of
the cards but this is not a coincidence
is it right like the whole point of the
trick is that Jack the hunter is always
with your yellow
card but why is that come back to your
book for a
minute what do you say it again sorry
always 16 cards up there are always 16
cards up this is important but I'm still
not sure why it's important okay so
maybe write down with me imagine you
have all of the cards here in a pile I
think that's actually enough right now
what happens physically as you divide
these into two piles right well let's
suppose I got my two colors
here do you want to deal left or right
first which way do you want to go first
left left of course left right should
have worked that out by now so your
first card on top it goes to the left
okay and then the next card goes to the
other pile it goes to the
right yeah so then card number three it
goes to the left and then card number
four it goes to the right what are you
noticing about all the cards that end up
on the left yeah Luna they're all odd
you've got the one the three the five
you're going to get the seven as well
and then what do you notice about the
cards on the right they are even even so
you've got the two the four you'll
eventually get the six and the eight
okay come back over to where Jack
is 6 and 16 sorry 6 and 22 I beg your
pardon 6 and 22 they're
both even so they're both going to end
up in this pile
right hey hold on a second though like I
kind of like assumed it was in this
position didn't have to be right what if
it wasn't in position six what if keep
on putting markers down what if it had
been in position
seven what would that mean for this card
down here remember you're adding
16 it's not going to be in 22 anymore
where's it going to be um it's going to
be in the odd and then the other and
then the target is going to be if Jack
the hunter is even like six so will be
the target 22 but if Jack the hunter is
OD so will the target be 7 and 23 do you
see this okay and in fact if we come
back over here you can see this happens
every time right watch let's do it again
left right left right left right and so
on huh there it is
again now you can actually see if I have
a look at this right how many cards are
there between Jack and your card you can
actually see them AR you how many are
there there are
three hold on a second we started with
16 and we split them in half what's half
of 16 eight it's
eight right now there are three cards
between them so when I do this Gap it's
not going to be eight it's going to be
four because I'm splitting into two I'm
Haring it every time this are you
following what's the next one going to
be two two and the very last one let's
keep on going it's when there
is there's the gap of two right there
here is as it were the gap of one can
you see that card one card two there's a
gap of one so what we're really doing is
does anyone recognize these numbers by
the way 16 8 4 2 and one does anyone
know what they're called starts with a P
you may not have answered it just yet
but maybe H what do you think pattern
very close oh I mean it is a pattern
definitely I mean they're harving every
time but the particular kind of pattern
this is called is and this is worth
writing down they're called powers of
two it's what happens when you double
two over and over again right
so we're right on the uh on the end of
the lesson now these powers of two are
what make the trick work right right so
how could we remember that third
question I asked you on the board how
could we adapt this trick so it would
still work but be different what's
something that we could do instead of
the way we set it
up yeah what do you reckon you could add
more and change it to a different Power
maybe that's right I could change it to
a different Power the next one after
that would be hm what's double 16 32
that's 32 do you see why I didn't do 32
the first time too big does anyone know
how many cards there are in a deck there
are 52 very close 52 so if I had 32
cards in each pile I just I run out of
cards in my deck does that make sense so
actually doing more you need more decks
what I could do though is I could do
less right I could have done this trick
and started here instead instead of
putting 15 cards in every pile I could
have put in seven and that would have
given me a gap of eight okay